is it wrong for an apple based channel
to say that i am more excited for the
galaxy note 22 i mean the s22 ultra than
the iphone 14 pro well we just ordered
ours in and i can't wait to get my hands
on it especially to do another blind
photo comparison challenge which are
super fun and they're super entertaining
so if you guys want to see another one
of those go ahead and click that
subscribe button down below now i'm also
going to be switching from my iphone and
going to the s22 ultra for at least two
weeks as we are testing it out but
potentially that could be my main phone
with my iphone becoming a side one
because i do still need it because of
seven specific reasons and the first one
is definitely the design now some of you
guys may know that this year i did not
go for the max model iphone for the
first time in years because the regular
13 pro had the same exact features so
why would i want this big s22 ultra well
even though the screen is bigger than
apples and the battery life is also
bigger as well as having additional
cameras and a built-in s-pen it still
weighs less than the iphone and it is
actually narrower as well meaning that
even though has a big screen it is still
easier to hold in the hand and of course
we had to go for the ultra model because
it has the best specs out of the whole
s22 lineup so if you want the most
features you have to go for that one now
i am so happy that they stuck with the
note design and now again with the
ability to fast charge up to technically
47 watts but of course most will use the
45 watt brick now i love this design and
i was sad to see samsung not release a
new note and just do the folds last year
with the rumors of the note lineup just
merging into the s series i thought they
were gonna keep it with that same
s-series look and just ruin the note but
thankfully they didn't do this and they
brought back the note design and now
that is the top line ultra series of the
s lineup and that just makes a whole lot
of sense i've owned many notes even the
very first one which i loved but this
design in my opinion is samsung's best
ever the s21 ultra is probably the most
ugly with a really terrible camera bump
in my opinion now i'm not sure if i like
the new design on the note better than
the previous one that had a single
camera bump but you guys let me know
your thoughts down below the second is
the screen now of course the screen is
very similar compared to b4 but it does
go down to one hertz to save battery
life and it's able to keep up 120 hertz
at the full quality instead of having to
compromise with the note 20 i actually
kept it at 60 hertz because i could
definitely tell the difference when you
lower the screen resolution especially
when you are reading text but what i'm
most excited for is the
1700 peak knit brightness display that
is crazy it's crazy that it's even
better than apple's xdr screens that hit
a thousand six hundred nits and i'm
excited to see how bright it gets when
you're watching hdr content and more so
than that how it does out in the sun
because they never reach the peak limit
when you're using it in normal sdr but
it should be better than before and the
third reason is videography
they are making this a huge point this
year now as far as the sensors and stuff
not a lot has changed but processing can
make a huge difference with the s20 when
they advertise 8k like crazy it actually
looked terrible even worse quality than
shooting 4k with the same phone because
of processing but with future iterations
they made it quite a bit better and with
the s21 ultra the ak video looked so
much better that we actually went ahead
and compared it to a professional 5 000
camera shooting 8k video and in good
lighting it really held its own
unfortunately it is still only 24 frames
per second which can make it choppy
sometimes but i still cannot wait to
test it out and with that i want to
check out the nitography that they're
calling it nighttime video now as you
guys know with photos processing over
the last few years an hdr stacking has
made quality so much better but when we
switch our iphones to video mode and low
light it still really suffers because
they don't have um the same processing
that you get with night mode photography
so i'm looking forward to seeing how
good this night video is in the real
world and of course with that we also
have the photography side which is
number four we've taken a few trips
within the last year and at those trips
i really wish that i had the telephoto
lens from the samsung camera in my
iphone the telephoto camera quality can
also get quite a bit better with
processing with digital zoom and of
course the iphone 13 did get a three
times zoom and it got quite a bit better
than the iphone 12 but it still cannot
compare to having an actual telescopic
camera and we also know that even the
iphone 14 will not get that kind of a
camera we have to wait at least till the
iphone 15. the s22 ultra also has that
three times camera just like the iphone
that helps out when you don't need to
zoom in that much and in the past they
have had issues with processing with
that camera and the smaller sensor but
processing should make this look quite a
bit better and i can't wait to test it
out and also the 108 megapixel mode
which same thing with processing uh you
didn't have as good dynamic range you
had other issues even though you had
more resolution and detail compared to
apple's 12 megapixel when you were in
that high-res mode it didn't look good
but processing should make this a lot
better and to make that processing
better we have the new four nanometer
snapdragon 8 gen 1 processor which is
the fifth reason now i don't think this
is as big of a deal as samsung wants you
to believe it is but it is really cool
to see a four nanometer processor be put
into a phone and of course that brings
out a lot of competition
to keep apple on its toes and not
slowing down with their bionic series
chips now cpu performance didn't get
that much better in single core and the
same thing with multi-core and it's
still behind apple quite a ways but the
real improvement comes in with graphics
performance we're seeing it increase
from 77 fps and gfx bench all the way up
to 115 which is a 50 percent improvement
in opengl and when geekerwon switched
over to vulcan it got an even bigger
improvement of 57 pretty much matching
the a15 in the iphone 13 which is a huge
increase in performance now apple has
always been ahead in benchmarks but of
course in a real world gaming test there
were a lot of times that the samsung
actually proved to be better so i can't
wait to test out my favorite mobile game
call of duty mobile but with that
performance increase we have a huge jump
in power usage as well this is likely
the most power usage in any smartphone
pretty much reaching tablet levels
basically the same amount of power as
apple's m1 which is crazy and with that
much power you have to be able to cool
it down and samsung does have really
good thermal solutions in their phones
way better than apple which is not doing
anything but with that much wattage you
are still gonna get throttling and
geeker 1 showed it off where it actually
slowed down to 66.8 percent of its full
performance under heavy stress tests now
that is pretty extreme and in real world
usage it probably won't be that much so
we will be doing another head-to-head
gaming comparison against the iphone 13
pro max so make sure you guys have
notifications enabled if you guys want
to see that number six is the s pen now
over the last six months or so i've been
really getting into taking notes from my
personal life my goals things i'm
working on and i really wanted the full
three to be a great device that can do
that for me and be a great phone but it
was just too big and it had other issues
as well and of course with the s21 not
having that slot like the note series
meant you had to have this janky flip
case that made a lot more bulky to be
able to actually keep your pen with you
but going back to this note it's all
built in and very useful so i'm really
going to be trying to make the most use
of the s pen and seven is the fact that
this might be possible this year because
i did not buy the pro max model i bought
the 13 pro which is much smaller lighter
easier to keep in your pocket as a
secondary phone and of course i'm really
stuck in apple's ecosystem i use a lot
of their exclusive features i'm loving
air tags i use um find my friends and my
items all the time and i have my apple
watch as well so i can't just get rid of
my iphone i do need it but now since i
won't have two huge phones it'll be a
lot easier to be able to keep that and
use something else so i'm super excited
to be able to test out the note 22 ultra
and use it
if you guys think the same let me know
down below we're going to get it in
we're going to do a ton of videos
head-to-head comparisons tests that you
guys don't see on other channels ones
that are fun and informative so click
that circle above if you guys want to
check that out and help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers and check
out one of those great videos right over
there that's been max and i will see you
in the next video
[Music]